[Applaudissements]
l'année dernière à pareille heure au
robert le tour des yoles ressembler
cette année à cause des nombreux bancs
de sargasses qui n'ont cessé d'envahir
la paix pas d'étape programmée du coup
les rues sont calmes les habitants animé
d'une morosité ambiante
lovett que ce n'est pas eu la veille de
noël approchent on est déjà prêt on
commence à préparer des choses on est
sonné mais par exemple samedi ou un
dimanche ici ses mots y a rien donc sans
le tour des yoles je crois que ça vaut
plus mort
les commerçants qui ont du mal à joindre
les deux bouts
eux aussi se plaignent des commerçants
suite fermé il ya pas mal de clients qui
viennent
c'est pour ça pour quelques clics
seulement dutoit rabusseau dans cette
commune d'environ 25000 habitants
asphyxiés par les odeurs d'algues
décomposer une partie de la population
semble s'adapter aux incommodités et
puis l'absence des yoles avec
philosophie
quant aux supporters inconditionnels ils
n'ont d'intérêt que pour la course
bonjour les conquérants ont eu bien mais
bien dans le basket voilà nouvelle faute
d' étape dédiée aux viols au robert
certains s'accrochent comme ils peuvent
à l'événement malgré le calme
les supporters des équipages natif de la
commune affiche une sorte de fierté qui
pourrait à la fin de la compétition
rejaillir sur toute la ville